uh why did you why did you do uh
america's got talent i think desperation
i think just like any i love the show by
the way oh i don't
i know because i just hung out with
howie four days ago he's a great guy
love him great guy really howie mandel
is a solid dude
and there i know a lot of comics that
have done the show which is
i feel like it's right for them it's not
right for me
i'll be honest with you i don't i don't
like fight with you
right yeah but i don't think it's right
for you
he just said he just i know i'm just
they're gonna fight now he you know what
the problem was that show is
it's a nightmare people i was i think it
was like six years ago or something and
i was kind of like
i just want to sell tickets on the road
i'll do why
i want people to come i just want people
to see my stand up
and uh i was doing a lot of road gigs i
was doing like headliner dates but
papered rooms right so those are tough
to build and act it's hard to write an
hour
of material when they're not your people
and uh
so i did agt it sucked i i remember
auditioning for it and they're like all
right we're gonna we're gonna see you
through and then
uh and then i literally it's i did the
thing out here in pasadena and uh
it was like a 5 000 person theater oh
wow nick cannon's like interviewing me
i'm making jokes he's like he's acting
sincerely like
these are jokes i'm [ __ ] making jokes
but then uh
i remember going on i'm freaking out i
get anxiety in these things
like are you i i when i watch the show i
always
know oh i'd never be able to do that the
pressure it's awful i mean i had already
done last comic standing and i hated
that and oh my god
you realize too these shows are all
about casting so i had a good set on
last comic and they just didn't move me
on they were like we're gonna not
and i was like why yeah but so i i'd
been through that already but i was like
i'm desperate i'll do
whatever it takes so i i remember doing
agt
just freaking out backstage and i'm
texting my mom like i'm freaking out
she's like read a book i'm like mom
read a book there's two [ __ ] fat
slobs from atlantic city dancing mambo
number five next
you want me to read like i think like i
can just focus like
like last comic standing sucks because
you're around comics and their anxiety
but you're around all walks of life and
they're like i can't imagine
there's like a talking parakeet right
next to me
and i feel guilty too because there's
like dance troupes like i'm a comic i
can go on drunk
these people are stretching they're like
they don't know what they're going on i
know
it's a nightmare another thing is is
that like i've done like
festivals with other comics right
oddball or whatever
and if you're nervous or whatever you
have other comics to like go to
and go you know and and they can give
you like you know
you just you're around your people yeah
with you
you're with the [ __ ] the ninjas
they're doing some sort of dance routine
it's brutal it's brutal now i remember
and they would [ __ ] with you they want
you to be a wreck because it's good tv
so they'd come in and be like
simon cowell's in a bad mood today i'd
be like
what and oh they'd be like simon he's he
hasn't eaten yet so he's very i'm like
feed him feed him why can't you like
there's food around did you meet him
yeah he okay so the first round
um it's in that big theater and i
literally watched two
really nice orthodox jews dan like do a
rap thing i thought it was pretty good
and i'm watching them
and simon's like you're dreadful you're
terrible you're never gonna be anything
and people are like boo
so i'm like oh [ __ ] this is i'm going on
to this the cat the the
what there's like a supervisor or
something there and she's like do this
joke i like this joke i'm like i'm not
doing that [ __ ] joke
like a dark joke they're gonna boo me
off so she pushes me out there i go out
and they're like i can tell they just
want to eat me alive so
and by they i mean uh simon yeah and he
was like so
like give me your worst gig ever and i'm
just like all right so i tell the story
about
a guy getting up out of the crowd and
spitting on me yeah and i figure like
maybe this will get them on my side a
little bit yeah
and i end up they simon even says well i
hope this is better and i was like all
right maybe i softened him a little bit
yeah set goes great i feel pretty good
about it
it was like a standing ovation in that
room if there's a hilarious clip of it
where they they cut it up for the thing
yeah and it's me telling a fart joke and
it just cuts to all the judges giving me
a stand
and it's like the most they're like
they're like well done
and i'm like man my mom is so ashamed of
this yeah so i
i uh i'm like wow that couldn't have
gone better i get out there like all
right we'll see if uh
if you move on in the next round i was
like they just told me i moved on
they're like well that's not how it
works i'm like i got four yeses
oh oh that anxiety so now there's the
anxiety of like we might not air this
and i was like
that's you put me through that and it
might and it went as well as possible
it's evil and then like a month later
they're like you're in for the next
round so like all right
i fly out it's like classic did they fly
you out
no they don't they don't fly wow they
don't fly they don't even pick you up at
the airport
i was like calling my manager at the
time like where are they they're like oh
they're not getting you i was like
i've been here an hour what the [ __ ] oh
my god so then i get to the hotel
there's construction so i don't sleep at
all the night
like they wake up they wake us up like
construction wakes up like 8 a.m
i i'm anxious i have no sleep they get
me there at 10 a.m
i go on at midnight so they're just
[ __ ] with me for like
14 hours i go on i follow some destiny's
child
like knock off and then simon eats them
alive
yeah and i go on after them
are these these aren't the live shows
yet right no i'm not it's not a live
show yet
yeah i go on and simon was like uh i i
do well i got it
it's like two and a half minutes i got
like two applause breaks yeah i'm
hitting pretty uh
not as well as the first round was it
more juice crowd it was not midnight
yeah yeah you know and uh george lopez
is one of the judges he was a nice
enough guy he was like i thought you did
well and uh
simon was like i liked you i liked you
better in the first round
and i was just like i mean it was a
better crowd like i don't know yeah yeah
so i kind of
don't have much and then uh they they
put me up against a mom named tape face
who was incredible
dude i crushed it that guy's awesome
yeah yeah it's
hilarious that my mom was even like you
had our vote i'm like well i know you
didn't vote for the cape face mom
but uh no he was great and and very nice
guy too
yeah i remember i think he just like a
residency in vegas if you're in vegas
you should see him he's really great
and i remember they put us against each
other and we both did well
and they were like people but they were
like we can't have two of you
all right so they they eliminated me but
did they error
that stuff the first two they combined
into like one long segment but it got
like it's like
back then it was like 10 million viewers
so so even that one spot was like
you know something yeah man but it
doesn't
it's just you're right it's not a loyal
audience and it's not it's really not
the right look for me
the reason why i say that is um there
are certain acts
i've seen where it's like either they're
in an impressionist
right right or they have a character
sure right
and you know and when i used to see
these people
at clubs and stuff i'd just be like it's
not the right environment for that type
of act
even a comedy club because comedy clubs
especially if you're at the cellar
or at like you know the comedy store or
whatever right it's like
they like traditional stand-ups right
like what you are right and also you're
very relevant and
i think you're edgy right yeah what
i said thank you yeah yeah yeah so when
i saw you on
american because i love the show right
yeah it's like
wow that's interesting because it's like
i don't
see you in that world yeah i think i was
just desperate i think you know the
the clubs got hard like those funny
bones like when
now and it's my people it's great but
like back then it was
they they were really rough i remember
walking audiences just because they just
they they didn't they had no investment
they got free tickets so they would just
be like you suck [ __ ] you
well yeah the funny bone in columbus i
guess
that's the best one i heard i actually
haven't done that one yeah i mean i i
don't know what happened i used to do it
every year
and then one year he just says i don't
want him anymore